Salut à vous peuple des Internet nous sommes presque à la moitié de ce calendrier de l'avent c'est le onzième jour nous sommes 11 décembre
et comme tous les jours à 6 heures du matin je vous parle d'un thème
mais toujours aussi d'un cadeau potentielle à Noël qui pourrait vous plaire
puisque à priori si vous êtes sur cette chaîne c'est qu'on à peu près les mêmes goûts et l'année dernière en 2016 et un petit
peu 2017 j'vous êtes parler de rhétorie de répartie de l'art d'avoir toujours raison
je parle de mon engouement pour ça c'est issu de l'art de la répartie de Schopenhauer
alors schopenhauer il a il a écrit ça hein l'art de la répartie qui est sûrement le plus grand traité de répartie
mais surtout le plus grand traité de mauvaise foi aussi
dans l'art d'avoir toujours raison qui existe à ce jour mais le texte n'est pas si simple à comprendre
c'est pas si évident que ça parce que la réflexion est très bonne et très pertinente et bien tu me crois tu me crois pas
Han qu'elle surprise il avait caché ça sur ses genoux il y a une édition qui est sorti chez librio qui coûte 3 euros
euh 1 2 et 3 euros je trouve pas ça cher du tout c'est aussi pour ça que vous en parle et
il reprend 38
des meilleurs stratagèmes de Schopenhauer et surtout il les commente
et c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est à dire il prend des exemples et dans les exemples il prend des exemples très contemporain
J'ouvre je tombe sur Socrate et Eutidem très contemporain exemple de l'exemple du stratagème 8
je vous le lis quand même le stratagème
il consiste à mettre l'adversaire hors de lui la colère etant mauvaise conseillère il ne sera plus en état de former un jugement juste
et de voir où est son intérêt
le moyen le plus sûr de le faire sortir de ses gonds et de provoquer ouvertement de couper les cheveux en quatre
sans jamais reculer devant l'irrévérence ça c'est le texte original de Schopenhauer et donc
là on à l'intérêt du stratagème et la mise en pratique
par l'auteur et ensuite exemple quand je dis contemporain il date un petit peu, c'est l'exemple du 27 octobre 1985
et c'est toujours plus récent que ce qu'avait fait Schopenhauer au départ
c'est une émission de télé sur tf1
sur un débat entre Fabius et Jacques Chirac en fait l'idée de Jacques Chirac était de casser/de briser
la belle image qu'avait Fabius auprès des français de sang froid de tout ça et il y arrivera avec ce stratagème la
la il y a Chirac qui dit les nationalisations sont un système qui a prouvé qu'il est mauvais
Je voulais faire un peu marionnettes ce sera plus clair ça c'est Fabius ça c'est Chirac et ça c'est les présentateurs
- des nationalisations - laissez passer monsieur Chirac sinon on va pas s'en sortir
- oui mais j'aimerais qu'il me réponde - écoutez l'Etat qui consiste à vouloir en permanence parce que ça vous gêne
interrompt pour essayer de déstabiliser l'adversaire elle ne sert à rien car ce n'est certainement pas vous monsieur Fabius qui allait me
déstabiliser vous imaginez bien - bon ne vous énervez pas ne vous énervez pas - j'ai de ce point de vue
au moins autant d'expérience que vous et par conséquent vous ne risquez - je reconnais que vous avez plus d'expérience politique que moi
- alors soyez gentil de me laisser parler et cesser d'intervenir incessamment un peu comme le roquet n'est ce pas
et là c'est à ce moment précis que
Laurent Fabius va faire un geste très énervé de la main, je vous laisse voir ça sur les internets on retrouve
encore la trace de ça et qui dit écoutez vous vous adressez au premier ministre de la france
non je parle à monsieur Fabius  représentant du parti socialiste alors cesser de -qu'est ce que c'est que ce comportement
et la Chirac lui prend tout son calme pour le dire écoutez monsieur Fabius
cessé de m'interrompre indéfiniment vous serez comme ça qu'elles sont mes raisons et en fait
dans le fond Fabius avait peut être raison sur les nationalisations à l'époque mais comme
il a été manipulé par jacques Chirac c'est lui qui s'est énervé réellement le premier qui est
émis en plus des gestes d'énervement et ce qui a un peu cassé son image à l'époque. voilà et dans le même état d'esprit il
existe un autre livre encore moins cher donc plus petit il coûte deux euros 99 lui
il y a des effets de malades qui s'appelle l'art de la répartie de Séverine Denis qui lui est chez first lui et chez librio
alors j'étais un peu surpris en achetant je pensais qu'on était un petit peu dans le même délire que ça et en fait oui
mais non c'est à dire que bien sûr on va voir plus sur la répartie que sur la mauvaise foi d'ailleurs ça c'est intéressant
la vraie répartie
arriver à contrer certaines situations il ya des bons mots aussi de répartie dedans genre des échanges par exemple il y a une
femme un jour qui a dit a Churchill si j'étais mariée avec vous je verserai du poison dans votre verre et Churchill qui
lui répond madame si j'étais mariée avec vous je boirai ce verre. Je trouve ça très marrant
après c'est peut-être une légende urbaine mais c'est toujours intéressant de
stimulant en tout cas d'imaginer ses réponses là et
pourquoi je dis que ça va un petit peu plus loin parce qu'on parle de comment capter l'énergie des échanges
les types de répartie les situations nécessaire pour avoir de la répartie est ce qu'on est obligé d'être drôles ou
est ce que tout le monde est drôle sans le savoir
comment être dans le moment présent
ici maintenant
mais là c'est intéressant, on n'est plus sur de la pnl et du
développement personnel mais on se rend compte que pour avoir de la répartie
il faut aussi être vraiment dans l'instant une espèce de truc ou nagui on dirait dans Friends, ou aware dirait Van damm
mais il ya un petit peu de ça
un des premiers chapitres c'est sur comment libérer son imaginaire aussi voilà il ya tout le processus aussi pour se mettre en condition et
optimiser sa présence
et optimiser sa présence
Et
optimiser sa présence pour après avoir la répartie je trouve que les deux s'associe très bien ensemble et c'est pour ça que vous en
ai parlé et que je les mets dans la description de cette vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo vous pouvez laisser un pouce en l'air si ça vous a plu
on se retrouve demain pour la moitié de ce calendrier de l'avent abonnez vous aussi si c'est pas déjà fait ciao
over clap je ne sais pas à qui je vole tout ça mais je le dis quand même